[Music]
take the sheep
so we're still going warm
[Music]
one more time he grabs my assembly
the which kizushi pattern is this front
inward right
so you jump rules he gets the aloha
you're gonna now know which kazushi
pattern is that
the back outward do you see he's going
he's going this way
so uh when you do it you don't want to
uh make him do some weird groucho marx
thing like that
[Music]
you want to take advantage that he's in
this one
foot up in the air so you keep him on
that one foot
boom right there
[Music]
oh don't pull them off
okay what you're doing is you come along
here and you go to the chihuahua you let
this hand die
you see i i have two hands and the two
hands help
you see
oh you use it don't go oh damn and then
switch hands you see that it gives you
both hats
that are useful to help
see the difference keep it alive each
hold on here
keep it alive both pounds
but he has this grip on here you see so
i can't
go and do is you see but it opens it up
to chihuahua so the hand he's robbing
keep the position right
don't freak out
so
hey